Transcription: Sophie Brigant-Derrien
Relecteur: Anne-Sophie Matichard
Bonsoir.
Je me présente,
je m’appelle Mathieu, j’ai 19 ans
et je suis étudiant en agronomie.
Quand j’étais jeune, il y a de cela
maintenant une paire d’années,
j’habitais dans le département de la
Haute-Marne, dans la ville de Langres.
J’ai eu la chance de pouvoir habiter
dans un petit hameau
avec un grand jardin
et énormément d’espace
pour consommer toute cette énergie
que j’avais en moi.
Je passais énormément de temps dehors
à découvrir de nouvelles choses,
à aller là où je n’étais pas allé
la veille,
et tout un tas d’activités
diverses et variées.
Je me souviens,
j’étais très amusé par le fait de tracter
des bâtons toujours plus gros
et vouloir les tailler
toujours plus pointus.
Au fur et à mesure des années,
cet attrait physique
pour la nature et la forêt
est devenu une véritable passion.
Et aujourd’hui, je souhaiterais
en faire mon métier.
Aujourd’hui encore, je passe
énormément de temps en forêt
à la découverte de nouveaux massifs
et j’ai à cœur de partager tout cela
avec mes amis.
Avant de continuer,
j’aimerais faire un petit sondage
avec vous :
qui parmi vous pense
que la forêt française
subit la déforestation?
OK, très bien.
Maintenant,
qui pense que la forêt française
ne subit pas la déforestation?
Oui.
Eh bien, vous avez totalement raison.
La forêt française
ne subit pas la déforestation.
C’est même tout l’inverse
puisque le taux de boisement
du territoire français
est passé de 26 à 31%
entre 1990 et 2020,
c’est-à-dire une augmentation
de 2,7 millions d’hectares,
l’équivalent de deux fois la surface
du département Île-de-France
en seulement 30 ans.
Cela peut peut-être vous surprendre
étant donné que, chaque été,
les médias diffusent
d’impressionnantes vidéos
de massifs forestiers qui brûlent.
Mais ces massifs, petit à petit,
avec les années, se recréent,
en partie grâce
à la régénération naturelle,
mais aussi, lorsque ces feux
ont été trop violents,
c’est l’homme qui les reconstruit
en les plantant.
Aujourd’hui,
la forêt française est partagée
par de très nombreux propriétaires,
et ces propriétaires partagent
aussi une contrainte universelle.
Je parle du réchauffement climatique.
Cette notion n’est pas nouvelle
aux yeux de la génération précédente,
et encore moins aux yeux
de la génération actuelle
qui est la mienne,
mais aussi la vôtre.
Je pense que vous avez tous déjà vu
au moins une fois ce graphique.
Il représente l’augmentation
de l’élévation des températures
en fonction des années et des scénarios
préétablis par les scientifiques.
De mon côté, ce graphique me fait penser
à un explorateur mondialement connu.
Je parle de Mike Horn.
Alors vous me direz,
où est le lien entre ce graphique
et Mike Horn ?
Eh bien, que ce soit dans ses interviews
ou dans ses vidéos sur Internet,
il a souvent l’habitude de dire, je cite :
« Dans la vie, on est toujours
dans la merde.
La seule chose qui varie,
c’est la profondeur. »
[Rires]
Eh bien, je trouve que ça illustre
parfaitement ce graphique.
Au plus optimiste,
on est un peu embourbé,
mais on arrive quand même à avancer.
Mais au plus pessimiste, on ne bouge pas
et c’est à peine si l’on peut respirer.
Tout ça pour dire
que les mentalités changent.
Les gens trouvent des initiatives
pour tenter de contrer ce phénomène.
Mais l’inertie du processus est telle que,
même dans les cas les plus optimistes,
il ne faut pas s’attendre
à des évolutions majeures.
Alors je repense à mes grands-parents
qui m’ont très souvent répété,
et ils avaient sûrement raison :
« Mathieu, il n’y a plus de saisons. »
[Rires]
Ce réchauffement climatique induit
de nombreux phénomènes
à la surface de la Terre.
Par exemple,
les dépérissements forestiers
sont de plus en plus importants.
Ils sont définis comme étant
un affaiblissement progressif
des massifs forestiers.
Et cela induit des changements majeurs
sur les paysages que nous connaissons.
Et nous savons que la France,
c’est aussi ça :
une diversité de paysages.
Cette richesse de diversité,
c’est avant tout le fruit d’une gestion,
depuis des décennies,
de notre patrimoine forestier.
Et comme les hommes de la forêt
ont l’habitude de dire :
c’est la gestion d’aujourd’hui
qui crée la forêt de demain.
Malheureusement,
les gens ont parfois du mal à percevoir
pourquoi ces coupes de bois
sont autant indispensables,
mais je pense que je peux vous aider.
Que vous soyez étudiant,
ou non d’ailleurs,
on ne va pas se le cacher,
la vaisselle,
ce n’est pas notre point fort.
On repousse constamment l’échéance
où il va falloir se retrousser les manches
et laver toute la vaisselle
qui attend dans l’évier.
Et plus on va attendre,
plus on va entasser,
et plus cela rendra la tâche
difficile et longue.
Eh bien, la forêt,
c’est sensiblement la même chose.
Plus on va repousser
ces opérations sylvicoles
qui nous permettent de l’entretenir,
et plus la forêt va évoluer, se dégrader.
Et lorsqu’il faudra reprendre le contrôle,
la tâche sera, elle aussi,
difficile et longue.
Alors, je parle de reprendre le contrôle
des massifs forestiers,
mais il faut savoir qu’il existe encore
dans le monde,
des massifs forestiers dont l’homme
ne maîtrise pas le développement.
Il s'agit de forêts primaires.
Et sachez qu’à seulement
2 000 kilomètres de chez nous,
en Pologne, dans la forêt de Bialovèse,
il existe encore des massifs forestiers
tels que celui-ci.
Mais dans la majeure partie du monde,
ces massifs sont extrêmement menacés
par la pression de l'industrialisation.
Cependant, aujourd’hui en France,
l’enjeu économique actuel
de la filière bois est trop important
pour que nous ayons affaire
à ce type de gestion sylvicole.
Il faut bien comprendre que le discours
qui vise à dissocier l'homme de la forêt
n’est plus du tout
d’actualité aujourd’hui.
Nous avons besoin de cette forêt,
car c’est le poumon de notre civilisation,
mais de notre côté,
nous nous devons de l’entretenir,
d’assurer son développement
et les produits de sa régénération,
parce qu’après tout,
c’est elle qui était là avant nous.
C’est à nous maintenant
de prendre soin d’elle.
Toute la difficulté se trouve donc là :
savoir maintenir en pleine santé
ce massif forestier
qui compose notre territoire
sans pour autant se contraindre
à prélever son bois.
Malheureusement, aujourd’hui en France,
partout sortent de terre
des plantations linéaires,
dépourvues de toute biodiversité
et d’esthétique.
Progressivement, on copie le modèle
de la surproduction agricole
et de l’implantation d’essences
à croissance rapide, comme le Douglas,
ce qui favorise cette industrialisation.
Alors, les entrepreneurs, les chercheurs,
mais aussi les gestionnaires forestiers
progressent ensemble pour tenter
de trouver de nouvelles solutions
et perfectionner la résilience écologique
des forêts,
définie comme étant la capacité
d’un massif forestier
à s’adapter aux variations climatiques.
Le but étant de créer des massifs
à la fois diversifiés,
mais aussi et surtout
spécifiques au milieu dans lequel
on souhaite l’implanter.
Pour cela, nous allons utiliser l’exemple
de la forêt domaniale de Chinon,
au sud-ouest de Tours.
Il s’agit d’un massif forestier
d’environ 12 000 hectares
majoritairement composé
de chênes sessiles.
Actuellement,
les zones en vert représentent
la compatibilité du chêne sessile
avec le milieu.
Jusque là, aujourd’hui,
rien d’alarmant.
Cependant, d’ici 2050,
les évolutions majeures du climat
entraîneront de profondes modifications
des caractéristiques des milieux.
Voilà donc, en 2050, la même carte.
Est représentée en rouge
la non-compatibilité du chêne
avec le milieu, à hauteur de 99 %.
C’est avec ce type d’observation
que l’on prend conscience de l’enjeu
de l’évolution du climat.
Il ne s’agit plus de faits énoncés
dans les journaux ou sur les réseaux,
il s’agit de faits bien réels
d’ici 30 à 40 ans.
On comprend donc pourquoi il est important
d’étudier les caractéristiques
de chaque essence
et du milieu dans lequel
on souhaite les implanter.
Cependant, cette démarche sylvicole
à elle seule ne suffit pas.
Pour cela, on utilise ce qu’on appelle
l’implantation de mélanges d’essences,
car c’est avant tout la diversité
qui permettra de créer cette durabilité.
Les forestiers appellent ça
la futaie irrégulière.
Il s’agit d’un mode de gestion
déjà mis en place
dans bon nombre de forêts
aujourd’hui en France,
mais cette pression constante
de l’industrialisation
tend à diminuer l’utilisation
de ce mode de gestion.
Le principe est relativement simple.
Il s’agit de maintenir sur un même massif
l’ensemble des stades
physiologiques des arbres.
J’entends par là le fait
qu’il y a à la fois
de jeunes plants issus
de la régénération naturelle,
des arbres plus âgés,
ainsi que le doyen des forêts.
Et c’est ce doyen qui sera
la source même de cette régénération.
C’est donc cette stratification
des volumes de bois
qui va pouvoir permettre
une souplesse de gestion importante.
Cette souplesse de gestion permettra
de pallier des demandes importantes
de la filière bois,
mais aussi de conserver des arbres
de haute valeur et de haute qualité .
C’est par exemple le cas
de la cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris.
Nous avons tous suivi cet incendie
terrible pour notre patrimoine.
Eh bien, aujourd’hui,
c’est grâce à des forêts
gérées durablement,
que l’on peut se permettre
de récolter ce type de chêne centenaire,
d’une qualité inestimable,
afin de reconstruire notre patrimoine.
Mais la futaie irrégulière,
c’est encore un autre avantage.
Et l’un des avantages majeurs est
la biodiversité qu’elle accueille.
Parce que les massifs forestiers
dans le monde, c’est ça aussi,
ce sont des réservoirs de biodiversité.
En France, 80 % des espèces
de mammifères terrestres
et 75 % des espèces de champignons
sont issus de ce milieu forestier.
Mais ce qui est pour moi
le plus important,
c’est le sol, le sol forestier.
À l’intérieur de celui-ci,
on retrouve une quantité
et une diversité hallucinantes
d’organismes vivants.
C’est ce qui fait
cette fertilité impressionnante.
Ce sol, qui est aujourd’hui le pilier
de la filière bois française,
si celui-ci vient à ne plus être fertile,
c’est tout un écosystème
qui sera voué à la perte
et qui entraînera avec lui
l’aggravation des phénomènes climatiques
que nous connaissons aujourd’hui.
Alors, les modes de gestion
doivent donc se baser
sur la protection de cette ressource.
Mais encore une fois,
l’industrialisation massive des forêts
tend à négliger
le renouvellement précieux
de cette ressource.
Sachez que je ne fais là
qu’effleurer le sujet
de la gestion forestière
et de ses enjeux.
J’ai totalement pris conscience
de ce qui nous attend
et des évolutions à mener.
Mais je sais que ma motivation
et mon enthousiasme
seront des facteurs qui me permettront
de toujours vouloir
en apprendre plus sur la forêt,
et je suis déterminé à trouver
des solutions de gestion durable.
De votre côté,
je ne vous demande pas, d’ici demain,
d’acheter 300 hectares de forêt.
Cela n'aurait pas de sens.
Mais je vous demande d'observer.
Je vous demande d’être attentifs
au monde qui vous entoure,
parce que la forêt,
ce n’est pas seulement un massif forestier
et un merveilleux lieu pour se balader
en famille ou entre amis ;
mais c’est aussi une énorme quantité
de réflexions et d’aspects techniques
pour concevoir à la fois
un système performant, mais aussi durable.
Peut-être que d’ici quelques années,
je pourrai revenir parler
des nouveaux sujets de recherche,
peut-être des découvertes,
mais aussi de mes nouvelles expériences,
qui, je l’espère,
seront grandissantes.
En attendant, je vous propose
de ne plus regarder au sol
comme nous avons l’habitude de faire.
Car cette vision est totalement
biaisée en forêt.
Les plus belles choses se trouvent
dans la cime des arbres.
Je vous invite donc toutes et tous
à sortir de chez vous.
Explorez les forêts
qui vous entourent,
prenez le temps de lever la tête
et d’apprécier cette nature qui évolue.
Appréciez le travail des hommes
et des femmes de la forêt qui,
chaque jour, veillent sur elle.
Appréciez la pluralité
des ambiances sonores
qui se propagent
à travers les troncs.
Tout ça pour vous dire :
soyez rêveurs, soyez curieux.
Laissez porter votre regard
et partez à la découverte
de la forêt et de ses secrets.
Merci.
[Applaudissements]